للمنتخب المغربي اشاده اخرى بما تحقيقه اا
قطر على المستوى التنظيمي في مقابله خاصه
بقناه الجزيره قال الرئيس الكولومبي
السابق ايفاندوكي ان دوله قطر قدمت احدى
افضل بطولات كاس العالم على الاطلاق من
حيث التنظيم والبنات التحتيه
الذي شهدته قطر وهي طريقه لتقديم نفسها
للعالم بامتياز بدون شاكيرا ان هذا سيذكر
بانه احد افضل المونديالات من حيث التنظيم
وبالنسبه لعشاق كره القدم ان تكون لديهم
كل الملاعب في نفس المساحه الجغرافيه
الصغيره نسبيا ليتمكن من رؤيه اكبر من
المباريات فهذا امر شديد الحدث وربما فريد
من نوعه في تاريخ كره القدم ولكن ابعد من
هذا التميز في تنظيم المونديال راينا
امتياز في تنظيم المتاحف والاماكن
السياحيه وتنظيم واداره الكثير من
الفعاليات الثقافيه اعتقد ان العالم يرى
افضل وجه لامه شهد التحولا وتريد اليوم ان
تشارك بشكل فعال في العلاقات المتبادله
الدوليه مع ثقافات اخرى ودول الاخرى بصوره
تجعلنا ان قطر انجزت هذا العمل الرياضيه
وقامت به باندماجها هيكليا في الوقت ذاته
مع بقيه العالم